hurry up
all right let's go
oh my God okay this is such a highly
anticipated movie The fandom of Mario I
don't know if people realize this but
I'm just going to point it out Mario is
the most popular video game of all time
so just to kick things off what is it
that we love about Mario so much whether
it's something from your childhood The
Nostalgia what is it about this guy that
we love
I I mean uh uh for me I play Mario you
have to answer it but I can't I think
like it's multi-generational right it's
like Mario is this sort of pillar that
supports the foundation of the childhood
of my generation of my kids generation
like there's so many people all of them
remember the first time they played
Mario Mario is the Everyman of the video
game Universe work in the plumbing job
yeah we're getting out there and
fighting against the Donkey Kong
monsters everyone can who can't relate
to Mario right also the theme song Maybe
the best theme song of all video games
I like to imagine like the guy who
pitched that who like came in the
Steelers like guys okay just lay it down
it goes wait that thought
you get it
okay
it's gonna get tricky right here
did you get that okay yeah put that all
down
wow
the composer is a genius is a Mario
composer well done absolutely you got to
wonder though if it was the first one or
they're like nope next oh yeah I think
that the Mario Brothers song should be
round now nope nope that might have been
like the hundredth one I'm telling you
listen
how are we going to top that yeah
exactly because it's it's kind of like
Jaws where it's just so simple but it's
so profound
you know what I mean you are a rock star
Jack I just want to go down the line
quickly and ask each of you to name you
can do both if you want your favorite
Mario suit or power up I I do like the
cat suit I think the catsuit's fun yeah
you know what I mean there's just
there's a there's a it's quick it's
frenetic it's
buoyant if that's the word I'm looking
for it is yeah
you know call me a traditionalist I'm
going to go old school just just the the
straight up mushroom power up the thing
that makes you go from just little to
Big just a regular just a regular red
mushroom with white spots on it
um I'm just gonna pick the best one by
far sorry you guys I know you're gonna
say the Superstar because you get it
yeah
and you're indestructible yeah you can't
beat that and you're like rainbow shiny
I don't know if it's called flower power
what the thing was the power up that was
like it was like on the fire one yeah
the fire one that was good because that
was like not only my big now I'm on the
offense yeah look out I'm like I'm
firing you know what I mean it's pretty
cool and then you could get hit and then
just go you're back to where you were
big you know what I mean like so that
was that was that's true you had to stay
big when you got hit how about you I'm
gonna just go just I think just the
basic ability to slam yourself into a
pile of bricks and find coins
that's tough to beat I mean I wish I
could do that yeah that did satisfy when
you just like do it yeah
was there a line from the game a sound
effect something that you got to do as
voice actors or say or a word that was
iconic to your characters that was the
most exciting and I'm going to start
with You Chris there were a few
catchphrases Mario has a couple
catchphrases it's a me you know let's go
and trying to find a way to put
incorporate those in this movie was was
actually kind of complicated because
it's a me is a tough thing to say to me
is a tough thing to say as a 40 year old
man I don't think I've ever said it's me
I thought it was pretty rad the way it
was addressed in the movie where it
starts off with like a commercial for
the Mario Brothers Plumbing
should I not talk spoiler when it's
right out the gate when it's in the
first five minutes of a movie it's not a
sport
if it's the first thing you're gonna say
that's true I don't know
guess what they're pretty early
anybody else any other iconic lines
anything I love Jack I love your open
the gates
yeah yeah I don't I don't I don't
remember uh if Bowser ever said that
before I don't is that is that an iconic
has he said open the gates before I
don't know if he said it before but you
made it iconic I wasn't well thank you I
wasn't thinking uh yeah to hit lines
that he'd said before I was just
thinking I'm going to go with full rage
and of demonic powers and that's why I
wore this shirt today I wore it
specially for Bowser because I think of
Bowser as kind of like a flaming Guy
Fieri ready to throw down at any
moment's notice where does that Fury
come from
Fury Fieri I just put that together
you're asking where does where does
Bowser's Fury come from
Guy Fieri's fear has been people make
fun of them constantly yeah so it brings
a fire to battle the haters but I have
Fury and rage that I'm not one I don't
want to talk about it but Bowser is you
know what Bowser's insecure at the end
of the day he's a jealous uh creature of
uh sort of uh Petty
um sadness and his his rage comes from
like his inability to communicate with
the people that he he wants to have
relationships with did you know we were
going to go down this road
imagine walking around with something
that heavy on your back constantly right
that's just got to be frustrating it's a
metaphor you know yeah it's right will
all of the great villains have this seed
of insecurity at their core that's my
theory
that's true I think that's true in uh in
uh movies and in life
okay
next question
can you tell us about what kind of Mario
we meet Mario's a little guy you know so
he's got uh he's got that attitude that
he wants to stick up for people he wants
to stand up for himself he never gives
up he doesn't quit he doesn't know how
to quit and um I think that he's he's
really confident and loyal he loves his
brother he loves his family and he
believes that um he should be doing
something special with his life and uh
yeah I think that's the the character of
Mario that is D that you did go deep oh
okay yeah you're on the ocean floor bro
thank you I want to thank you for going
deep also because I felt like I was
going to be the only one that went
really deep you
were so deep
that you dragged all of us down in a
good way
down
Charlie this is called Super Mario
Brothers so we have to talk about Luigi
he is an internet favorite people love
Luigi Luigi reminds me of the person you
can relate to he's got some fear tell me
about this brother relationship that
they have in this movie uh people uh
people like an underdog you know and uh
he doesn't have a lot going for him he
just loves his brother and you know he's
willing to follow him down the pipe of
uh life I guess and um I was thrilled to
play him because uh it's nice to play
somebody tall
[Laughter]
doing all the scripts he would go into
the voice recording booth and you would
just sort of like I like to just work in
the dark
just kind of find the character and
there's a lot of research and a lot of
you know I call Jack and he he said he
talks a lot with Christian Bale and they
kind of like walk me through I did get
some acting tips not from Christian but
I heard about his method yeah and so
you're able to get into the core of the
guy so I love this Christian Bale is
that what you did to channel Bowser you
went full I want to make clear Christian
Bale is not in the Super Mario Bros
don't say that
[Laughter]
but uh yeah or is he I'm a very
Christian Balian actor when you get
right down to it
Seth uh when I was a kid my first
video game experience I had one of those
gaming watches and it was a Donkey Kong
oh yeah oh yeah and my brother and I had
like we went we were fighting like a
finger was broken fighting over playing
that game because we wanted to play that
game so bad
you are I think probably the only actor
in history that was in a Steven
Spielberg movie and played Donkey Kong
in the same year
and that's incredible and I set out to
do it
more than anything both those things
were on my vision board
yeah that is yeah so what kind of what
can you tell us about the jungle Kingdom
that we're going to see I know Fred
Armisen is playing your dad tell me
about the father-son relationship and
what are we going to see in Donkey
Kong's World in this movie
um it's pretty amazing it's visually
expected they make carts there's it's a
cart driven economy they they seem to
thrive on uh yeah it's cart based
Commerce me and Fred Armisen in real
life have a pretty awkward relationship
so it is reflected well
I'm not alone in that uh
in general yeah I think Donkey Kong it
is one of my first like video gaming
memories I think in real in the correct
me if I'm wrong but the Mario brothers
in the gaming world are introduced
through Donkey Kong correct only one of
them
so they didn't go that way with the
movie they they decided to use the
brothers as the way into Donkey Kong
Keegan yes toad is adorable
this tools of toad adorable you are a
Shakespearean actor and from what I
understand you really channeled like you
really got into the heart of this
character to Plato So can you talk a
little bit about how you found the voice
of toad the director and I um I I I was
working with my um uh my my partner in
like acting coach on on the on the work
and I was trying to I was channeling
actually a friend of mine and the way
that he sees the world and the way that
he kind of looks at things in this and
syntax and stuff like that and I we
brought that to the director
and uh and and then the voice was it was
like we knew it would be higher in a
higher register so part of what I wanted
to do was hit the syntax but also almost
pretend like I was sucking on a helium
balloon while I was doing the recording
like at least like thinking helium and
trying to get trying to get the sound a
little more just like like pinching the
sound like the you know a person sounds
when they're doing helium and that
you're pinching it a little bit and just
I was trying to and then he would go
higher I'm like a little bit as king and
I know I know it's I'm so sorry a little
bit higher I just want to do whatever it
was because he was in Paris and I was in
the states just like three in the
morning he's doing this recording
session I'm like anything you want mine
so it was just getting high it was
trying to get as high as we could and
still have a certain Comfort level
within the voice you know what I mean
which is exactly how I played Hamlet
exploratory experience you know to try
to try to find the right spot and try to
get the try to get those those rhythms
in a place where it felt like it would
be towed but kind of a new version of
toad at the same time you know and that
and also like what yeah yeah so that was
that was kind of that was the process
maybe you can talk and you and Chris can
talk a little bit about this
relationship between Mario and Toad in
this film I I mean for for me my big
thing about toad was that I think he's
been looking for an adventure in his
life I think he's been wanting to be the
guy who could step up and help Princess
Peach in a way that would be you know
like he want he's like I'm up for an
adventure I'm I think like when they
discover each other without without you
know no spoiler alerts here but when
when they when they encounter each other
the first time I think partially what's
going on is Toad's kind of out in the
perimeter of Mushroom Kingdom because he
wants to make sure he kind of like wants
to make sure nothing's going down I've
got this situation a lock and that he's
he wants to make it so I think that's
when they just when they find each other
that's why he doesn't see him in the
city he sees him out in the wilderness
because he's like he's patrolling he
want he wants something to protect he
wants his life to have some kind of
meaning he's got that backpack on oh
he's ready oh he's ready to go ready
he's ready to go man he's out the Wilder
people if you want to add to that in any
way what is Mario's perspective on that
friendship well I think you know it's
like Mario was moving it comes into
Mushroom Kingdom it's a little like if
you were a new kid at school
and all of a sudden this kid comes up
next to you and you're like I'm not sure
like I kind of want to do this on my own
a little bit because I'm not sure if I
want to let if we're supposed to be
friends like I'm at a new school I feel
like Mario was like that toad kind of
just like sticks to his side and then
and then he's like all right you know
what for better or worse this is my
guide this is my guide through this
world and they become Bros and uh he and
you know toad has an extraordinary
opportunity to to step up and do the
thing he's always dreamed of doing with
his like saving his uh his world and his
beloved princess something I think so
exciting is I know just from the I
haven't seen the film but from the
trailers I've seen
there's so much detail there are so many
callbacks to every single Mario game and
every era every every era of the game
and you can go for hours like watching
all the little like Easter eggs that
they've just been put into that so can
you tease to the audience kind of like
each of you or something that you can't
that you're allowed to say something you
can't wait for audiences to see whether
it's a kingdom
power up something uh
that because it just looks incredible
from what I've seen in that first little
uh sneak preview that they do where
where you're in the forest and you and
and I find you and I'm like hey come you
know come to this place this guy's
brother is in trouble you know come to
this place I think that we've shown that
already but in that one you can hear you
can see as we're walking through the
town that there's a guy standing at a
stand I don't know if you remember
seeing this standing at a stand and he's
buying an antique and he goes are you
sure this is going to work and he goes
it's easy just blow on it you just blow
on it and you're going as and there's
little Easter and you go oh my God just
like back in the day when you had to
take the cartridges and
yeah that's right and you're going oh my
God that's brilliant it's absolutely
brilliant and there's and there's those
little seeds those little Easter eggs
throughout the the film it's fantastic
and and not just yeah not just to the
sort of lore of owning a Nintendo or
having the old 8-bit cartridges that you
had to blow on but also you know it's
really promises this sort of almost
Nintendo Universe in a way like this
Nintendo Cinematic Universe because you
meet us you meet Mario and Luigi early
on and they're in a pizza parlor and
you're seeing all over uh it's like
punch out pizza or something so it's all
based on the game punch out and so that
you have all like the characters from
from that game Jack anything to add
stuff Charlie I thought it was pretty
rad when you get to the Mario Kart on
the Rainbow Road scene yeah uh yeah that
was my favorite thing
to blow some people's minds because it's
it's uh just as exciting and fun as like
when you're a kid playing that game uh
it's uh pretty impressive yeah
um and also anytime that Bowser's on
screen is like whoa yeah he's doing this
sometimes it felt like they got
Metallica to play I don't know who that
is but it's like some real heavy metal
Monster Energy uh I was into it sorry to
give myself a shout out
really really good really good
there is dude also Mario Donkey Kong
Showdown
exactly pretty good yeah
I'm good not for a kid's movie I'm just
really happy to be a part of it uh yeah
you know Luigi's Style just happy to
have anything just to be you know in the
game and uh player B but you know just
just in the mix it's pretty sweet I
think he went method because that is so
Luigi that's Luigi right right there
thank you all so much thank you this was
wonderful
cannot wait to see this movie this is
only level one it might be game over for
the interview but you can go get your
tickets right now today on Fandango
you'll get a power up if you do it
thanks for joining that was great that
was so many puns that was well done